rénovation extension reconstruction ou
maintenance 100 % des lycées
d'ile-de-france seront l'objet d'une
intervention d'ici 2027
c'est l'engagement pris par valérie
pécresse dans le cadre du plan
pluriannuel d'investissement qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
émincer simple on va doubler le montant
du plan d'investissement dans les lycées
et on va en plus réparer les dégâts
quand il y à des problèmes de
maintenance soit un total de cinq
milliards d'euros sur dix ans dont 1
milliard pour l'entretien du patrimoine
immobilier
donc on va avoir un tableau avec pour
chaque lycée un carnet d'identité un
carnet de santé c'est à dire qu'on aura
une connaissance physique du patrimoine
immobilier et tous ses besoins en termes
d'entretien dans les yvelines le lycée
de la plaine de neauphle à attrape le
lycée 17 mar à maurepas ou encore le
lycée rené descartes à montigny le
bretonneux seront donc rénové autre
enjeu pour la région diviser par deux le
délai de construction des lycées en le
portant à cinq ans ainsi vingt mille
huit cent nouvelles places seront créées
à travers la livraison de 12 lycées
neufs et la réalisation de 23 extension
notamment à mantes-la-ville carrières
sur seine ou encore sartrouville huit
mois d'audit ont été nécessaires pour
élaborer ce plan d'urgence et le constat
est alarmant selon la majorité à la
région un établissement sur trois est
vétuste et la hausse des effectifs n'a
pas été anticipé le débat en séance avec
l'ensemble des élus et programmés les 9
et 10 mars prochains